>> IF YOU HAVE UNDERWEAR ON, YOU
ARE OVERDRESSED.
>> HAVE YOU HEARD WALK A MILE IN
A MAN'S SHOES?
I PUT ON A PAIR OF MY HUSBAND'S
SHOES AND MY GOD, WERE THEY
COMFORTABLE.
I GET WHY MEN RULE THE WORLD.
NO HIGH HEELS.
THAT'S MY TIME.
I'M MRS. MAISEL.
THANK YOU AND GOOD NIGHT.
>> GET READY FOR A WHOLE NEW
PERSPECTIVE.
>> MRS. MAISEL, TO SEE A WOMAN
GO ON STAGE AND DO STAND UP.
>> MAYBE SOME DAY YOU WILL BE UP
THERE.
JUST BE HONEST AND SAY WHAT'S ON
YOUR MIND.
WHAT ABOUT DOING A SET TONIGHT?
>> COMING UP NEXT, GOT -- THIS
CAN'T BE RIGHT.
SHE SWEEPS THE FLOORS HERE.
RITA MAY JOHNSON.
>> HI.
>> REMEMBER, JUST SAY WHAT'S ON
YOUR MIND.
>> NOW IS IT JUST ME, OR DOES
THIS BITCH LOOK LIKE --
[ BLEEP ].
>> IT'S THE RAUNCHIEST MISS
RITA.
A SHOW THAT IS A LITTLE LESS
STYLIZE AND A LITTLE MORE IN
YOUR FACE.
>> I WENT TO THIS LADY'S HOUSE
AND I OPENED THE DRAWER AND 100
DILL DOES.
YOU KNOW WHAT I TOLD HER?
YOU ONLY GOT 99 NOW.
>> HOW LONG HAS SHE BEEN ON FOR?
>> AN HOUR AND A HALF.
>> IS THAT THE LIGHT?
>> I GOTTA SAY THAT RITA'S GOT
SOMETHING.
>> WHAT IF SHE STARTS COMPETING
WITH ME?
>> [ BLEEP ] [ BLEEP ]
[ BLEEP ].
>> I DON'T THINK THERE IS MUCH
OVERLAP.
>> WHAT'S WITH THE HAT?
>> WITH TONY.
>> THIS IS NOT HOW IT'S DONE,
MIDGE.
>> PAPA, I'M GOOD AT THIS.
>> SHE IS GOOD AT THIS.
>> THIS DUDE KNOWS WHAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT, AIN'T THAT RIGHT
[ BLEEP ].
>> MIDGE TAKES RITA UNDER HER
WING.
>> YOU MAY WANT TO SPEAK ABOUT
CORE SUBJECTS OFF MYSTICALLY.
>> AT LEAST TURN ON THE SO YOU
HAVE SOMETHING TO WATCH.
>> GET THE AUDIENCE ON YOUR
SIDE.
>> RIGHT.
>> YOUR [ BLEEP ] IS SO SMALL --
SHE KNOWS WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT.
>> FROM THE CREATOR OF MAISEL
PRODUCERS FROM DEF COMEDY JAM.
>> THIS NEXT COMIC IS A LOT MORE
CLEAN CUT AND WHOLESOME, WELCOME
MR. WILLIAM COSBY.
>> THANK YOU.